-The president is peddling
another insane conspiracy theory
about the death toll
in Puerto Rico
as Republicans brace themselves
for the midterms.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look".
[ Cheers and applause ]
The president has been
going on TV basically every day
to try to convince people
that he's competent
as a potentially devastating
hurricane
bears down on the East Coast.
Lately, he's taken to posting
videos to Twitter,
but it's clear from
the quality of these videos
that he's just making his
staffers point a camera at him
while he rambles
off the top of his head.
Yesterday, for example,
he tried to reassure people
that his government was ready
for Hurricane Florence.
-Hurricane Florence
is fast approaching.
It's going to be here
over the next 48 hours.
We'll handle it.
We're ready. We're able.
We've got the finest people,
I think, anywhere in the world.
Get out of its way.
Don't play games with it.
It's a big one.
We are ready.
But despite that,
bad things can happen
when you're talking about
a storm this size.
It's called "Mother Nature".
You never know, but we know.
[ Laughter ]
-That video -- That video
is like a local news report
where the meteorologist
called in sick
and the sports guy had to
fill in at the last minute.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
The hurricane came to play,
but the first responders
left it all out on the field.
In the end,
it comes down to turnovers.
[ Normal ] If you want people
to take your message seriously,
maybe have higher
production quality
than a mid-level YouTube star.
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
The storm is big.
Get out of the way,
but before you do,
please like and subscribe.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal ]
And if that didn't do enough,
that didn't do enough to relieve
people's worst fears,
the White House also released
this photo of Trump on the phone
while Chief of Staff John Kelly
and Vice President Mike Pence
look at some printouts.
Oh, well, that's reassuring.
They look like
they're ordering Chinese food.
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
I'll go ahead and dial.
You guys just pick four
or five things we can share.
[ Normal ]
And as a life-threatening storm
bears down on the Easy Coast,
Trump has also been
bragging about
his handling of the humanitarian
disaster in Puerto Rico,
which left nearly 3,000
American citizens dead.
Now, that is the official death
toll from an independent study
commissioned by Puerto Rico's
government,
and yet, our deranged president
doesn't believe it.
-He says...
He then says,
in a second tweet...
-That's the official death toll,
you lunatic.
Now we know
why he's so orange --
his brain
is just melted pumpkin guts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-We don't need a book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We don't need a book,
we don't need an anonymous op-ed
to tell us that the president
is an addled narcissist
who peddles one
conspiracy theory after another.
He said the first black
president wasn't born here,
said three million people
voted illegally,
said Muslims celebrated on 9/11,
and thinks you get super powers
from staring
directly into the sun.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
May the power of the sky lamp
fill my muscles!
[ Normal ]
Now, Trump's incompetence
and erratic behavior
are posing major political
problems for Republicans
as the fall campaign season
gets underway.
A slew of new polls
have given Democrats
a major edge
in the midterm elections.
GOP Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
even admitted this week that
some of those races
will be tough
for Republicans,
using a colorful metaphor.
-But we know this is gonna be
a very challenging election
on the Senate side.
I'll just list you
a bunch of races
that are dead even.
Arizona, Nevada, Tennessee,
Montana, North Dakota, Missouri,
Indiana, West Virginia,
and Florida.
All of them too close to call,
and every of them
like a knife fight in an alley.
I mean, just a brawl.
-I seriously doubt
Mitch McConnell
has ever been in a fight...
or in an alley.
[ Laughter ]
He should use a metaphor
he can relate to.
[ Imitating Mitch McConnell ]
These elections are like when
you order a steak medium-rare
and you get it medium
and your wife says you should
send it back,
but you just eat it,
and then your wife thinks
you're a coward.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But she doesn't say that.
She's just real quiet
the rest of the night.
It's like that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal ] Now, one --
one of those knife fights
is happening in Texas,
where Democrat Beto O'Rourke
is running neck-and-no-neck
with Republican Senator
Ted Cruz.
In public,
Republicans are bullish
on Cruz's reelection chances,
but this week,
we found out that
they are much more pessimistic
in private
after the "New York Times"
obtained private comments
from a top Trump aide
suggesting that Cruz might lose
because no one likes him.
-At a private gathering
over the weekend,
White House Budget Director
Mick Mulvaney
warned Republican donors
and party officials
that they party was battling
serious vulnerabilities
in the upcoming midterms.
According to
the "New York Times",
Mulvaney raised the prospect
that Senator Ted Cruz of Texas
could actually
lose his bid for reelection
because he's not seen
as likable enough.
-He said this in private --
-So, Ted Cruz debased himself
by cozying up to Donald Trump --
a guy who insulted his wife
and said his dad killed JFK.
And in return, they call him
unlikable behind his back.
That is rough.
You know, I feel like I should
say something nice
about Ted Cruz
just to balance it out.
So, let me try.
He's -- Let's see.
He's...
not here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Democrats face an uphill
battle to retake the Senate,
but if they're close in Texas,
they have a chance,
which is why the GOP
is trying a new tactic
to motivate their base --
dangling the threat
of impeachment.
Last week, for example,
Trump told his supporters that
if he's impeached
by a Democratic Congress,
it will be their fault.
-They like to use
the "impeach" word.
"Impeach Trump".
Maxine Waters --
"We will impeach him,
but he didn't do anything wrong!
It doesn't matter.
We will impeach him!"
It's so ridiculous,
but we'll worry about that
if it ever happens.
But if it does happen,
it's your fault
'cause you didn't
go out to vote.
-I'm sorry,
real quick, real quick.
Can we just go back
to that first part?
-They like to use
the "impeach" word.
-Yeah, that's the word.
"Impeach" is the "impeach" word.
Did you mean to say
"the I-word"?
Because that would make sense.
Trump has zero subtlety.
He's like a guy spelling out
dirty words around his kids.
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
She had nice b-o-o-b-s.
You know, boobs. Boobs.
[ Laughter ]
And Republicans
are also marshaling
every member of the Trump family
they can get,
like Donald Trump Jr.,
who's been campaigning for
Republicans across the country
and did a rare sit-down
interview with ABC this week
about the midterms.
-Trump Jr. says
the November midterms
will inevitably
be a referendum on his father,
one where historical odds
suggest Democrats
could win back the House.
And he worries that could
spell political catastrophe
for his father.
-So, our people,
the MAGA people,
they have to turn up.
They have to get out and vote.
And I think we can
break history.
-Oh, I think
you broke it already.
The rest of us are trying to
piece it back together
like a vase after a house party.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"What happened to your vase?"
"Oh, some douche came over
and drank beer out of it.
And then I said
'You got to pay for my vase',
and he said, 'Do you know
who my dad is?'
And I said, 'Everyone knows
who your dad is
because you have
the same name, dummy'.
And then he started to cry
and said 'I wish I was Ivanka',
so I felt bad and I said,
'It's okay,
you don't have to
pay for the vase',
and then he said, 'Sike!'
and broke another vase.
He's a real [bleep]".
And Don Jr. isn't the only
Trump son showing up on TV
to support his father
and get Republicans out to vote.
Yesterday, Eric Trump
went on Fox News
and rambled about
the possibility that
Democrats might impeach Trump
if they win in November.
But the most jarring part
of that interview
came when Eric was asked about
famed journalist Bob Woodward's
new book "Fear",
a damaging insider's account
of the Trump White House,
and he decided to toss out
some casual anti-Semitism
that was not only offensive,
but very hard to follow.
-You can write some
sensational nonsense book.
CNN will definitely
have you on there
because they love
to trash the president.
It'll mean you sell
three extra books,
you make three extra shekels --
I mean, at the behest
of the American people,
at the behest of our country.
-Not only is that anti-Semitic,
but you don't know what the word
"behest" means.
[ Imitating Eric Trump ]
My father's amazing.
He's the "behest" president
we've ever had.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal ] But Democrats aren't
running on Woodward's book
or even impeachment, really.
They're running entirely
on issues like healthcare
and specifically,
Medicare for all --
an idea that not too long ago
was considered
a fringe pie-in-the-sky idea
and is now so mainstream,
former president Obama
endorsed it last week.
-Democrats aren't just
running on good old ideas
like a higher minimum wage.
They're running on
good new ideas
like Medicare for all.
-Damn!
When Bernie Sanders heard that,
he got so excited
his hair combed itself.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Who knows?
Who knows what's gonna happen
in November?
But this week has shown that
the choice could not be clearer.
I don't know if
the blue wave is coming,
but if it is,
the president better...
-Get out of its way.
-This has been "A Closer Look".
[ Cheers and applause ]